It's Toritei
Ace's physical condition,
shut up Dj
Ace's goal isn't to be a big shot Yeah, I
'm going out of my way to take the heads of four schools
Not raising ma's rank There is a purpose to
become stronger
Promises  I can't
do it Oh, that's my goal It's
ridiculous
Oh
, you're carrying that much
burden on your back as the commander of the 2nd Division of the Whitebeard Pirates Even though
he's like
Proneo,
oden is still like family
We all have the same desire to get rid of
it,
and I was happy when I heard that this country would be a country where everyone can eat to their heart's content.
[MUSIC]
What's wrong with your trafficking hahahaha